wirklich 750 millionen dosen das klingt
erstmal sehr sehr viel ist das zuviel
oder ist es sogar zu wenig wie muss man
sich das vorstellen die wir brauchen wie
am ende wirklich die frage ist immer wie
definieren wir wollen wir alles damit
infizieren wen möchte die firma das
alles verkaufen
es gibt ein paar dinge die wir noch gar
nicht wissen erst mal wie häufig muss
man sich selbst impfen lassen damit man
ein entsprechender schutz bekommen
ich gehe davon aus dass wir mit einer
einmaligen impfung nicht ausreichend
geschützt werden sein und dann gehe ich
davon aus dass biontech nicht nur in
deutschland verkaufen will sondern auch
weltweit auf den markt kommen und
insofern ist natürlich so eine zahl von
750 auf die ganze weltbevölkerung
unterbrechen und dann mehrfach impfen
wollen gar nicht so viel
überhaupt einen impfstoff oder ist es
sowieso wichtig dass verschiedene firmen
dann hoffentlich relativ gleichzeitig
impfstoff auf den markt bringen können
genau das ist absolut das was ich mir
wünsche weil die 750 millionen viel
klingen aber für die gesamte welt und
wir wollen ja möglichst weltweit
strategien hochfahren
das wird nicht reichen und bevor wir
wieder verteilungskämpfe haben dass man
zwei drei klassen gesellschaft bei der
verteilung haben wird wäre es schon
wünschenswert wenn viele hersteller auf
den markt kommen die dann eben
entsprechend produzieren können die
meisten von uns ist es natürlich viel
wichtiger wann es dann diesen impfstoff
gibt als von wem an denen dann
tatsächlich bekommt womit können wir
ungefähr rechnen kann man jetzt wo die
forschung immer weiter geht schon
konkretere zeiträume genutzt dann soweit
ist bleibt schwierig an märz gehört von
biotech dass sie erwarten dass sie ihre
daten in der oktober anfang november
bekommen
die müssen dann natürlich entsprechend
aufbereitet werden den behörden zur
verfügung gestellt werden dann kommt es
zur prüfung und dann produziert die
firma wahrscheinlich parallel schon
diese dosen aber also könne neben ihren
impfstoff erst wirklich verteilen und
und kann angewendet werden wenn die
zulassung erfolgt ist also ich bin
weiterhin
überzeugt dass wir vor frühjahr 20 21
doch kein mensch auch in der breite zur
verfügung haben werden muss er sagen
selbst das wäre für eine impfung extrem
schnell vom beginn der forschung bis zum
fertigen produkt wie sicher ist denn das
ganze wenn es dann so eilig passiert
normalerweise lässt man sich jahre dafür
zeit eine sehr wichtige frage und das
ist immer etwas wo man vorsichtig sein
muss wenn ich schnelligkeit
möglicherweise vor der sicherheit
herrscht oder oder vorrang hat die
äußerung von dort fahren um die
zulassung des russischen impfstoff sie
hätten ja so ein bisschen befürchtung
was das alter angeht aber in europa bin
ich mir sehr sicher dass die sicherheit
absoluten vorrang hat vollständigkeit
mehr nachrichten und bikinis nur weil
die schau dich je das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht abonnieren